welcome back we are taking your calls at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go to our caller
from the 3:04 area code who's calling
today from 3 0 4 hi David
my name is Chris from West Virginia how
are you today good how are you I'm doing
fine thank you so I had a question about
I I've read an article about how Mitch
McConnell was actually trying to
eliminate the $600 per week that the the
people on unemployment are receiving
extra yeah so people know what that is
unemployment is a state program
different states have different levels
of unemployment benefits because of
coronavirus the federal government is
enhancing unemployment by up to $600 a
week in addition to what you get from
the state that that's what Chris is
talking about good right so what do you
personally believe his motivation is
behind that why why would he do that ok
so it's essentially a way to force
States to have to reopen and if you have
more and more people who are lacking the
money they need to make ends meet you
are going to create a situation where
they are more likely to take the risks
associated with going back to work I
mean it's it's really as simple as that
yeah we could say more about it we could
say more about I mean listen I think
it's short-sighted because obviously in
the short term it might get more
businesses reopened if in the long term
it spreads infection it's going to lead
to more and subsequent closures but that
is what seems to be at the root of it
yeah I believe that if it keeps going on
like this that a lot of people are going
to die yeah we're gonna have to be
forced to read you know to close again
and I just don't I just don't understand
how they could how they could really
live with themselves after doing that so
I agree with you now if there's another
reason so I'm I think that's the main
reason but if there's another reason why
Mitch McConnell is doing it I mean
listen Mitch McConnell is generally
speaking
skeptical of of social welfare programs
in general so I think any opportunity
Republicans have to cut social welfare
they will do it but at least with regard
to the virus that's that's what what I
think is going on for states to open by
cutting unemployment benefits okay well
that actually makes a little more sense
now
I appreciate your time David thank you
very much all right Chris from West
Virginia very much appreciate the phone
call let's go next to our caller from
the nine-oh-nine area code who's calling
today from 9:09 I David my name is Jane
hey Shane what's up I was calling to ask
you about drummers I want to know who
your favorite drummers are oh my
goodness there's so many I mean you know
it depends on the genre you know you've
got somebody like the great late John
Bonham from the 70s rock era Steve Gadd
is a tremendous drummer Vinnie Colaiuta
you there's just so many so many
drummers you know in the sort of Latin
space TD Ortiz is fantastic it's it runs
the gamut there's just so many different
great drummers out there Carter Beauford
you know from the sort of Dave Matthews
genre whatever that genre is it's a it's
an almost limitless list we yeah nice
choice is already really cool that's
that's my only question okay I
appreciate you answering it and I
appreciate your book recommendations as
well all right thank you so much very
much appreciate the phone call thank you
see ya all right take care